welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and with guardians 3 getting Gamora back
with the gang and Ant-Man 3 getting
Langs fighting Kings we already knew
2023 was already set to bang let's not
forget that the mcu's strongest Trio of
super ladies the Marvels are also coming
to hang and with the crazy wave that
Carol Danvers and Kamala Khan suddenly
and mysteriously switched places at the
end of Miss Marvel's first season we
already know that that movie is set to
be Cosmic as hell with even more
surprises in store but what if I told
you that Marvel Studios has been setting
up for a major surprise reveal of a
certain Marvel hero that many people
especially black nerds like myself have
been begging Marvel Studios for forever
now that's right everybody I'm talking
about blue Marvel y'all and I'm gonna
show you guys where I think Marvel
Studios hid that clever little blue
Marvel Easter egg just for you my nerd
babies but first head on over to new
rockstarsmirch.com to pick up our newest
latest Obsession shirt or any other of
our amazing merch options over over
there all that cool stuff over at New
roxasmerch.com so check that out right
now but all right guys I believe that
Marvel Studios has been setting up a
major blue Marvel surprise for each and
every one of us and I think they first
started doing that all the way back in
the blessed year of 2019 the year before
the world went to [ __ ]
when one Captain Marvel movie came out
specifically during a flashback sequence
or a story of a mysterious Cosmic hero
is told to a young Carol Danvers by her
older brother Steve and passed down by
an adult Carol Danvers to a young Monica
Rambo take a look huge Rumble throughout
the cosmos shook the Moon and the Sun
and the stars in the sky
a while away flew up throughout the
night
you Denver seem to be telling a child
Carol Danvers about the story of this
mystery male hero from the past named
Alouette who used to live on Earth but
apparently had to leave the planet in
response to Something in the cosmos that
was causing the moon the Sun and all the
stars in the sky to shake and Rumble
wonder what happened to like a Celestial
art or something was it like a Galactus
fart man I mean that dude eats planets I
imagine his farts are pretty nasty and
it's a story that seemed to have an
effect on both childhood Carol and
Monica and likely fueled their love of
flying aircrafts and spaceships alike
with that higher further faster
mentality however my nerd babies I do
not believe that this is just a story I
believe that this young Monica mistakens
that blue tinted shooting star in the
sky as this Alouette space hero for a
reason because I have had the strongest
belief for months now that the Captain
Marvel sequel the Marvels will reveal
this Alouette as one Alouette Brashear
the blue Marvel Now for those of you
unfamiliar with the blue Marvel
character first of all shame on you I'm
kidding no shame here everybody starts
somewhere but you guys should know that
blue Marvel is actually an incredibly
cool and badass Genius of a Marvel hero
who is actually active around the 1960s
doing cool [ __ ] like stomping meteors
flying sinking battleships to safety and
stopping hydrogen bombs from exploding
innocent people to death as hydrogen
bombs are prone to do don't set one off
because people will die
and in the comics he was actually
Scientist by the name of Adam Brashear
who got his superpowers as a result of
an antimatter energy reactor explosion
from a test run gone horribly wrong
because that's what happens in the
Marvel Universe only nerds get super
powers because only nerds are that
curious
and everybody on the planet love the
blue Marvel so much man because he saved
the planet so many times they were like
blue Marvel hooray we love Blue Marble
until they found out the worst news of
all time that blue Marvel was black
he was black and they were like oh all
that cool [ __ ] is suddenly less cool for
some reason like literally all the white
racist Americans of the 1960s were so
scared of what a super-powered black man
were due to the fabric of society that
JFK himself asked Adam Brashear to put
down the blue Marvel mantle forever
which Adam being a war veteran who loves
his country did so reluctantly for you
know the good of his bigoted country
however he would return to active duty
during the Modern Age of Heroes to help
the Avengers stop his best friend turned
evil bad guy Connor Sims AKA Auntie man
from destroying the world because Connor
got crazy god-like Cosmic superpowers in
the same accident that Adam did so the
whole really complicated Thing feel like
we're gonna see Connor or Sim very soon
in the MCU but anyways this all being
said the main reason why I believe this
Alouette figure is going to be the MCU
blue Marvel Beyond just a shooting star
reference is because of why Alouette
left the planet in the first place
because in the story in the movie it was
apparently because there was some type
of Cosmic Rumble happening throughout
all of space that even shook the Stars
which is odd because something
suspicious similar happened to Blue
Marvel as well in fact it was actually
the focus of Decades of blue Marvel's
life well into his years of retirement
because you see much like the Ant-Man
family of nerds uses pintech to shrink
their way down to the much smaller
hidden microverse underneath their own
Universe there are beings on a higher
Cosmic plane in the Marvel Universe with
a similar type of curiosity and lust for
adventure an adventurous being of
massively sized proportions called the
infinite who's trying to make a trip
from his macroverse to the smaller
Marvel Universe but unfortunately
because the infinite didn't know how to
shrink himself as well as Hank Pym could
the infinite in men's size would cause
ripples in space time a couple of hours
before he was set to materialize and
arrive and accidentally destroy the
planet with his mask because he was too
big to land on Earth or even in our
reality but luckily for Earth Adam
Brashear had been tracking the
space-time Ripples and keeping the big
ass infinite from material Rising for
decades because every time the infinite
would fail to materialize in the Marvel
Universe thanks to Adam brashear's
intervention they would just choose
another moment in the future to try to
materialize to you know like when the
infinitech tried to accidentally crush
the Earth in 1998 before Adam and his
son had to head to Machu Picchu and use
Adam's Tech to send him away and this
happened three years until blue Marvel
along with his modern ultimates team
found a way to safely shrink the
infinite to normal size and they were
surprised to find out that he wasn't
this huge Galactus threat but actually
there's a super chill scientist guy who
was just curious and wanted to meet
everybody he was he was a nice man I
like the infant this all being said I
believe the MCU is teasing a similar
thing for the live-action Universe with
a gender swapped blue Marvel instead I
believe that Alouette Brashear in the
MCU went off into space to try and
figure out just what was causing all
these rumbles in space time rumbles that
are likely caused by a king the
Conqueror shaking things up with his
inevitable assault on the timeline of
the MCU and who knows maybe Alouette
Brashear never came back to Earth
because Alouette got whised away to the
present day or another time period by
Kang but I do know what you guys are
thinking Mt why do you even think that
Marvel is going to gender swap blue
Marvel in the first place like what are
you stupid Adam Brashear is Adam
Brashear not out of Webber's here I'm
gonna need you guys to think about it
okay the Marvels are a team of women led
by a woman in the MCU if the MCU is
going to introduce the original Marvel
of the Universe from the 1960s in the
Marvel's movie it's likely not going to
be a male because that just that's just
a weird message but rather the fourth
member of the mcu's team of Marvel X
which is something that I believe Nick
Fury was teasing at the end of Captain
Marvel with her name Marvel sounds a lot
better you know like the Marvelettes
foreign
ERS from the past so I believe that the
Marvels Were Meant to mirror the
Marvelettes by having four super powered
women on the team Carol Danvers Monica
Rambo Kamala Khan and Alouette Brashear
the blue Marvel and having Alouette B
blue Marvel makes sense considering a
strongly Carol and Monica already look
up to this superhero type figure I feel
like Alouette Brashear will be to them
like you know Isaiah Bradley was to Sam
Wilson in Falcon and the Winter Soldier
but that is just my crazy theory about
blue Marvel in the marbles what do you
guys think do you think that after
Quantum media we could potentially see
the infinite come to the MCU or do you
think that this could just be a Kang
thing let us know in the comment section
below but thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Mass retainment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but
most importantly you can follow the new
rock stars wherever we are on the social
medias and thank you guys so much for
watching this video I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time bye
[Music]